okay what i'm about to tell you is going
to make a lot of parents feel
better about the stacks of cash they've
spent on
barbies insider reports has a new study
that says playing with dolls
helps kids develop social skills and
empathy
commissioned by mattel the study out of
cardiff university
looked at boys and girls brains while
they played
with barbies and they found that the
posterior superior
temporal sulcus the part of the brain
responsible for social interactions
and empathy lit up
far more when kids played with dolls
okay than when they played with tablets
which is just horrifying but also
hopeful
so my daughter frankie she loves barbies
so
much she loved baby dolls and she loves
barbies and speaking of barbies did you
know there's a brand new doll in town
straight from the 19th century
it's suffrist susan b anthony suffragist
susan b anthony rockin the frock and the
vote
and she joins the rest of barbie's
inspiring women collection
we're so happy to have them here today
please welcome
it's tennis hero billie jean king
and civil rights icon rosa parks
artist frida kahlo first
woman to ride in space sally ride
aviation pioneer amelia earhart
founder of nursing florence nightingale
and the first lady of song ella
fitzgerald
i know and
whoa
[Applause]
oh my god it's courtney from the
american doll collection from the 80s
not a barbie but a very dear friend of
the show nonetheless
hey courtney these are great women to
learn from wait
i'm sorry what was that oh you think i
should get a nancy reagan doll or that
mattel should incorporate that
you know i used to hang out with nancy
back in the 80s
yeah i did i did the just say no
campaign with her
until i just said yes and finally
this story comes from missouri where a
25 year old woman is making harley
davidson history
she is the first certified black female
technician in the entire state
and she's here to tell us about it
please welcome paris mcgowan
hi paris how are you
doing great i know that some families
love a station wagon
but the mcgowan family prefers a hog
will you tell us about your love of
bikes
well my uncles and my dad they rode
and as a young child i remember sneaking
into the garage and trying to sit on
them
but what really inspired me to ride was
my mom
writing whenever probably 10 years ago
and she was accepted into the motorcycle
community and me being her little mini
me
i was also accepted early on
i mean that is just so cool your
mom on a harley when did you get your
first bike
so i got my first bike two years ago
and when i first got my bike i didn't
know
anything like completely nothing
so i decided to continue to ride for a
while
and then next thing i know i enrolled to
mmi
motorcycle mechanic institute where i
learned how to
work on bikes and i mean
it's just been an amazing journey me
being the only female
in my graduating class and
now i have my dream job i work at big
saint charles harley-davidson
and it's just a snowball effect so in a
few years
i'll be a master tech no
it's just it's so mind-blowing and it
really makes me want to ask this
question which is
i'm reading this book untamed right now
by glennon doyle and i think a lot of us
think that there is sort of this preset
box check life we're all supposed to
live and you went after your dreams and
it sounds like your family
you know i don't know if they supported
you or not but do you have
today it seems like they did
so definitely when i announced to my
family that i was going to mmi
they were behind me a hundred percent
what do you say to people who like
really just think that you know
life is short things are scary we all
want to live our best
life what's your advice really quickly
for them
so really quickly i just say move
forward and let those negative comments
definitely fuel your fire to push you to
do
more and go beyond the norm no one can
stop you or stand in your way of your
dreams
well i think people need to hear that
right now and paris you're incredible
thank you so much for coming on our show
thank you paris live your dreams
[Music]